hi so there you have it dinner is over
the kids have all gone home
um and it's day 19 I got a fair amount
done today I I'm getting better now at
deciphering the articles from Chosun
Ilbo
very interesting and I then read you
know I go through blinking and then read
them on my iPad read them on my iPad
either in ilink or even in the in the
app itself in link not the app in link
itself on my iPad which is great um then
I have done a few more articles from our
library because then I get the sound as
well um did a bit of listening when I
was driving I had to drive out and pick
up the food was about a half hour there
half hour back it's at one of our
favorite restaurants it's a little bit
further away from home um had a question
today which I want to talk about the in
today's a little video on my youtube
channel someone said ask me two
questions first of all if your approach
to language learning is heavily sort of
focused on listening and reading then of
course you'll only know the vocabulary
for that specific area that you are
focused on and you won't know the other
vocabulary and the second question was
in today's world don't you think
everybody is just gonna speak English
and it won't be so necessary to learn
other languages those are the two
questions I think they're interesting
questions first of all you know yeah in
when I read and listen I go wherever my
interest takes me and you'll learn a lot
of stuff but even today for example I
did some articles from Chosun Ilbo one
was about this whole issue of the
dispute between Japan and Korea over the
comfort women and I discovered a whole
bunch of stuff that I didn't know I
didn't know that there was a cartoon
exhibit in France where there was a
French excuse me where there was a
Korean exhibit where some cartoonists
have depicted this the plight of the
comfort women and then that the Japanese
embassy protested which strikes me as
very strange if if a cartoon exhibit the
some the Japanese put up an exhibit
about the sufferings of people and here
Simon and Nagasaki I have trouble
imagining that the American Embassy
would protest then the president of NHK
which is the Japanese public broadcaster
which people in Japan pay for every
month he decided to get up and say you
know the whole issue of the comfort
women who were recruited forced
recruited in most cases probably there
was some you know ladies of the night
who were happy to be prostitutes I mean
every war has its prostitutes and its
camp followers but but many of them were
forcibly recruited and so he got up and
said you know this is not so unusual it
happens in every war which again I
hadn't realized but that's very
extraordinary that the president of the
Public Broadcasting Corporation who
probably is not very well informed on
history would get up and make these
gratuitous comments about something that
probably you know has to be thoroughly
researched by historians what actually
happened why would the public
broadcaster make comments like that and
he was subsequently grilled by the
Japanese diet and of course you have to
remember that Japan is a democracy and
right now they have a bit of a
right-wing government which is you know
has a bit of a revisionist approach to
history but that there are other forces
in Japan who will you know try to defend
their position so I mean there can be a
variety of positions but anyway this
whole issue which is very interesting
interesting to see from a Japanese
perspective from a Korean perspective so
that's one thing that I stumble across
by reading the Chosun Ilbo there was
another one there about dementia on the
Chosun Ilbo and talking about how this
sort of attitudes towards life you know
being purposed minded the purpose fallen
active and so forth staves off dementia
and we should look there rather than any
miracle cures for solutions so politics
dementia then I've been listening as
well to some sort of common dialogues
plus I have my KBS drama
doesn't do so actually I listen to quite
a variety of things and I think we go
where our interest takes us and we may
concentrate on certain subjects for a
while and then we move on to other
subjects and the bulk of the vocabulary
you know is common as they always say
you know a small percentage of the words
account for 70 80 percent of the
vocabulary so you're constantly
refreshing the basic words connector
words why they're for beakers because on
the other hand and so forth and then as
your interest takes you somewhere you
then get into the specific vocabulary
but that's not a problem I mean
certainly not on link I just got start
saving those words and I may stay in
economics for a while or I may stay in
politics or I may stay in a medical
there was another article of Chosun Ilbo
about new ways of dealing with you know
knee and hip replacements and using
different approaches and stuff like that
so ever you go so I don't see that as a
problem at all I think people are
naturally curious oh and that was one of
the things they said about staving off
dementia is people who have a high
degree of curiosity about things that
that is very very important so be
curious and if you are curious and if
you are motivated to learn languages and
your curiosity takes you to different
subjects whether the economics politics
music art nature whatever it might be
that's gonna be good for your language
and it's gonna be good when you approach
my age for staving off dementia now I've
forgotten what I was gonna say no and
the other thing that he mentioned was
this person who asked me a question on
my YouTube channel here I said with
English don't you think that other
languages won't be necessary all I can
say is I made that little video of me
going into the Chinese restaurant just
to show you I go there I speak a few
words of Cantonese I go there regularly
we speak Cantonese
he speaks English but if we can connect
in Cantonese it's different at least for
me it gives me a tremendous sense of
satisfaction if I were when I was in
Russia I was so well treated in st.
Petersburg and Moscow plus I was able to
stave off not dementia but people wanted
to gouge me for taxis and stuff like
that because I speak Russian similar
experience in Slovakia Czech Republic
you know China Japan and I'm sure if I
go to Korea and can speak Korean I'll
have the similar experience so how can
you know I'm not saying everyone should
learn languages but the rewards of doing
so personally business-wise culturally
connecting with people are enormous and
I don't think the fact that English
becomes the lingua increasingly the
lingua franca of the world because it's
practical and useful is going to take
away the rewards of learning languages
so those are the two answers to that
person's questions and I'm kind of
upbeat today and I hope all of you out
there are upbeat who are doing the
challenge I checked on the list I'm one
of the more active people I would rather
be well down the list I want other
people to be more active I have the
feeling that today you know there are
some days you feel you're basically
standing still treading water and some
days you have a feeling that you're
better that you're reading better that
you're understanding better today was
one of those upbeat days where I feel
I'm doing better not tomorrow but
Tuesday I speak with joo-hyun with whom
I spoke say a year ago and I'm very
curious to see if I'm better able to
understand her and if she and better
able to express myself than a year ago
just based on these two weeks that I've
been involved in the challenge so up and
Adam everybody